about taking risks in your 30s i'm
turning 32 i'm a fan of it i messed up
in my 20s
spending any time judging yourself about
your 20s
is a waste of time you're [ __ ] 32. i
was stocking shelves in a liquor store
at 32.
i've been driving uber doing deliveries
i feel like you can do more yeah so do
more
and don't judge that either you're
grinding you're making an honest day's
living there's nothing wrong with that
either
my point of view is that it's way early
most 32 year olds today don't think it's
early because
we grew up i'm only a decade older than
you in a generation that demonized 30.
you're a young [ __ ] kid who gives a
[ __ ] if you sucked in your 20s and what
do you think
i should push myself into youtube you
know what i would say based on your
questions
there's nothing you should do you need
to focus on what you want to do
what you should do is look yourself in
the mirror and say what what do i think
i'm decent at
and what do i like and do one of those
and if you're lucky enough that what
you're good at
you like then it's really [ __ ] the
moon yeah i've just gotten a lot of hate
on like the small videos that i've
already done
i get hate every day you've gotta
practice not valuing other people's
opinions
from your mom to a stranger